back in the winter
a mural popped up in the middle of leeds
it saluted calvin phillips a son of this
city
who they knew was a bit special
now phillips has played every minute of
england's tournament so far
and has proved that he is the business
calvin grew up over there he just over
that side of the
housing estate there high school's over
that way yes that's where we went to
family academy
and then his mum's where mum lives over
there so it's quite a good circle really
close circle which is
like say he still is around here so he's
still in his area which is brilliant for
us
paul and ian used to drop him off back
home after training at workley football
club in the west of leeds
to see their calvin now running
england's midfield
is a bit special even when it was cold
or it was snowing
it'd just come off and smile even if you
lost drawn i'll win
he just smiled all the time and they
were a pleasure to coach
really well in the game against um
croatia was it when he knocked the ball
through for
for sterling to score we've seen him do
that loads of times it's
the same little run the same run as if
you're not having this ball off me
and then he pushes it through gap then
we've seen him do it here haven't we
he's done it before for us
the man on calvin phillips's shoulder in
the mural is south african defender
lucas radiby he was known as the chief
in the famous leeds united side
of the 90s he's one of the best players
i've seen
you know in this era you know who can
play that position
in a way that he does for club and
country a great platform
you know to showcase and represent you
know
a holistic picture of what it means
to be a food a professional footballer
you know from the streets
of in the community you know to the helm
you know of the best in playing against
the best in the world
he has been nicknamed the yorkshire
pierlo after the italian great
andrea pierlo but calvin phillips
is now his own man on loan to england
but at home just here tom parmenter
sky news leads